[Music]
elephants are so
different from us anatomically that you
would think there would be very few
parallels and yet the more we learn
about elephant society the more
parallels we see
they seem to have very strong social
bonds
females stay in their family groups
their whole lives
and the males will stay in their family
group until they become teenagers and
then they'll move out and they'll
hang out with other males in what's
known as a bachelor herd
the calves get raised by their relatives
as well as their moms so
sisters brothers aunties cousins grandma
all contribute to the raising of the
calf much like we used to
[Music]
elephants are really amazing at staying
in touch
elephants will communicate with each
other using vocalizations
making sounds that are within human
hearing range but we know that they also
use something called
infrasound which is a very low frequency
sound and the thing about infrasound is
that it travels over
very long distances it can travel many
miles and so we believe that elephants
when they separate
from each other in groups that they will
keep in touch with each other
using infrasound and they will use that
to coordinate their movements with each
other eventually
meeting back up together again for us in
the western world
and in big cities with so many people
loneliness is a problem it's a massive
social
illness
the behavior of elephants suggests that
they are aware of death
and that they do grieve and show emotion
when members of their family
die and they also show interest in the
remains of
elephants that they might not have known
and i quote someone called kyle owens
who was working in burkina faso in 1986
he witnessed a remarkable scene
while watching a herd of eight elephants
with a tiny baby
he saw that the baby was ill and
throughout the morning
the mother tried everything to raise the
calf to its feet he says that at dusk
he returned and the baby had died his
tiny body was barely visible
as the other elephants had covered him
with dirt and grass and leaves
the mother positioned herself over her
child and began to rock
occasionally other elephants would
stroke her back affectionately or
intertwine trunks
but she continued to rock as darkness
fell like elephants who grieve
it's normal and it's very common and
something that we're all gonna
experience in life
even though you have to go on without
this person in your life
you can live through the memories that
you've had
over the years
[Music]
elephants touch each other with their
trunks and this physical contact
seems to provide comfort so an elephant
that has appeared distressed
when another other elephant comes over
to it and seems to be comforting it
using its trunk and touching it
the other elephant seems to then relax
and seems to show less distress
so similar to to hugging comfort
affection
touching hugging kissing it's quite
a reassurance that okay there's some
support there you want people to feel
supported you want them to feel like you
know what they are part of this society
they're part of this world and they've
got a purpose here